c'est un personnage un peu oublié le roi
henry deux araignées 12 ans de 15 147 à
459 12 ans pendant la renaissance ou le
château de saint germain prend une
certaine place le roi y passent en
moyenne 58 jours par an saint germain en
laye et naturellement le siège de
nombreuses décisions on prend des actes
politiques et on prend également des
actes diplomatique les relations
internationales se nouent et se dénouent
à saint-germain-en-laye aurait donc de
l'évolution de la politique d'henri deux
ans nous avons à ce sujet la chance de
présenter ici prêté par le musée
national de la renaissance un objet tout
à fait extraordinaire qui est en forme
de livre avec une couverture et un
feuillet centrale pour cette exposition
le musée d'archéologie nationale
rassemble une centaine d'oeuvres
découverte de la personnalité du
souverain
la production artistique de cette époque
et des instants marquants du règne qui
démarre sous des tensions entre son
entourage et celui de son père l'une de
ces tensions s'est incarné dans le dos à
l fameux qui a opposé approche de futurs
henry 2 qui est encore dauphin qui
s'appelle la châtaigneraie et approche
de la duchesse d'étampés la maîtresse de
françois 1er
le baron de jarnac beau-frère de la
duchesse une tension qui amènera un duel
entre les deux hommes peu de temps après
l'accession au trône de henry de jarnac
donnera son fameux court aux jarrets de
la châtaigneraie
c'est la première exposition consacrée à
ce roi une mise en lumière d'un
souverain éclipsé par son père et son
entourage son épouse catherine de
médicis ou encore sa fille marguerite de
valois la reine margot